in 1992 the country of Yugoslavia was
falling apart it was right after the
Soviet Union falling so there was kind
of Chaos in the region and all of these
states were declaring independence
Bosnia and hovenia was one of the
countries that decided they wanted to be
their own Nation the problem was there
were three different ethnic groups the
largest of these groups were the Bosnian
Muslims or the bosniacs but the other
major ethnic group the Bosnian serbs
didn't want to be a minority run by
Bosnian Muslims so they declare their
own country and their nextdoor neighbor
Serbia steps in and supports them
sending in the military marching across
Bosnia claiming territory kicking out
Bosnian Muslims and croats the other
ethnic group and it led to this horrible
conflict throughout the early 90s that
is a real Telltale sign of how the world
shouldn't act when there's ethnic
violence I made a whole video about this
using a map because I wanted to
understand this conflict better if you
want to go check out that video it's on
my YouTube channel